an unusual marketing scheme targeting
women congratulate them on their
pregnancies even if they're not pregnant
yowza women nationwide say they've been
getting letters and gift cards in the
mail the Better Business Bureau says
it's received more than 95 reports of
what it calls a questionable marketing
scheme our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Warner's here with
the privacy concerns and I could see
this this could spot spark a lot of
interesting conversations at households
so without Heinie's letters and
evidently it has women and their mothers
who get the cards and wonder is there
something you haven't told me that is
your way of telling me yeah I mean we
all get these solicitations in the mail
right insurance mortgages you name it
but what if a company sent you a letter
saying congratulations you're going to
have a baby that's what's happening to
some women who say they find it very
disturbing in greeting card style the
marketing materials say holy guacamole
you're going to oval a baby inside what
looks like a handwritten note from
someone named Jenny be complete with
smudges it looks personal and
liinahamari says at that point I was
pretty confused and startled because I'm
not pregnant
turns out this was a marketing idea from
a company called mother's lounge a
wholesaler of mom and baby products from
Utah inside the envelope for gift cards
that's supposedly totaled nearly $250
along with coupons the first thing that
came up on our online search was a
thread from reddit and it appeared that
there were others in the country that
were receiving this on Facebook one
woman said the letter arrived on the
anniversary of her miscarriage another
said she received a letter addressed to
her deceased daughter reading the
personal message she said was hurtful
beyond belief the Better Business Bureau
says it's unsure what mailing lists the
business is using but not all of the
women who receive these mailings are
pregnant the BBB is Jayne rub people are
very concerned when they get this
because they want to know what list they
are on that says that they're pregnant
and the BBB says there's another issue
those gift cards they say something
Zoomers in the past have complained that
adding a gift card to their orders
online appears to increase the shipping
cost the shipping price should not
increase if you're using a gift card or
a discount that's misleading mother's
lounge company officials didn't respond
to our request for comment but said in a
statement to other media outlets that
the people who receive the mailer had at
one point subscribed to an opt-in list
for maternity deals and coupons through
a third-party marketing company
information it says is only used
internally but Lina cam Rahui who also
happens to be a privacy lawyer says to
her that's bad enough it was really
intrusive I felt like they were assuming
really highly sensitive personal
information about me in an inappropriate
manner
well the BBB says the added costs with
the gift cards appear to cover the
majority of their value the agency and
CBS News could not reach mothers lounge
the FTC sent gum rally information on
ways to avoid fraud when she complained
the agency told us they take consumers
reports seriously but having a baby is
just such a potent thing in your life
it's such a milestone such a powerful
marker that it's just something you make
a sales pitch on I don't well and you
don't want your mom calling you and
saying Oh your husband or your boyfriend
or you know I don't know I don't know
how you mail out something like this on
a mailing list you bought off of some
third party in your tent it's just it's
so if you receive an officer like this
an officer an offer like this in the
mail what do you do you can complain to
the FTC or you you know complain to the
business but ultimately you probably
just throw in the trash and hope your
mom didn't see it good advice yeah Anna
thank you very much